estamos en el complejo de colonias de
pingüinos de magallanes punta tombo
punta claro y lamentablemente tenemos
que compartir una noticia que es muy
desagradable porque alguien construyó un
camino atravesando una parte de esta
colonia y eliminando destruyendo todos
los nidos que estaban a su paso
[Música]
i
se ve claro una clara destrucción de
hábitat que será tan importante para
esta especie que es muy fiel asumido y
que es donde se encuentra con su pareja
año tras año viven 35 años veces hemos
seguido pareja por 17 años juntas pero
si no hay nido no hay sitio de encuentro
y es el lugar donde ellos crían a sus
pichones
[Música]
es importante destacar que esto es un
hecho muy excepcional porque la mayoría
de los propietarios de campos son
aliados de la conservación que permiten
compatibilizar la producción ganadera
con la conservación de sus especies de
fauna y también en muchos casos hacen un
desarrollo sustentable ecoturístico
[Música]
estamos en una de las colonias más
grandes del mundo de pingüinos de
magallanes es un sitio muy importante
que además es un destino internacional
que genera fuentes de trabajo genuinas
para la economía regional de esta
provincia
[Música]